i understand we have a verdict all right
are we ready for the jury
yes your honor
all right just uh for everybody in the
gallery reminder this that this is a
court of law
uh and uh regardless of the verdict i
will not tolerate any outburst
whatsoever okay thank you
um yeah
so
if i can have the attorney's approach
all right ladies and gentlemen of the
jury what i need you to do i need to
give the forms back to you
when you find for a defamatory statement
one or more you need to fill out the
compensatory damages it has to be at
least a dollar for compensatory damages
and up to whatever you feel the damages
should be
and for punitive damages you can put a
zero there or you can fill out that as
well but i'd need those uh lines filled
out okay all right so if i can have you
retire back to the
liberation room and do that for me okay
all right so we'll be in recess till we
hear back from them don't go too far
okay
thank you
so
shall we try this again all right
let's do that all right we're ready for
the jury
all right mr four person is this the
verdict of the jury
all right is it unanimous
thank you sir jamie
in civil case number cl 2019-2911
mr depp's claim against ms heard
one as to the statement appearing in the
online op-ed entitled amber heard i
spoke up against sexual violence and
faced our culture's wrath that has to
change
in the washington post online edition
quote i spoke up against sexual violence
and faced our culture's wrath
that has to change end quote
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes
has mr dent proven by a greater weight
of the evidence
that question the statement was made or
published by ms heard answer yes
the state question the statement was
about mr depp answer yes
question the statement was false
answer yes
question the statement has a defamatory
implication about mr deb
yes
question the
defamatory implication was designed and
intended by ms heard
answer yes
question due to circumstances
surrounding the publication of the
statement
it conveyed a defamatory implication
to someone who saw it other than mr deaf
answer yes
do you find that mr depp has proven by
clear and convincing evidence that ms
heard acted with actual malice
answer yes
two as to the statement appearing in the
op-ed entitled a transformative moment
for women in the washington post print
edition
and the online op-ed amber heard i spoke
up against sexual violence and faced our
culture's wrath that has to change in
the washington post online edition
quote then two years ago i became a
public figure
representing domestic abuse and i felt
the full force of our culture's wrath
for women who speak out end quote
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes
has mr deb proven by a greater weight of
the evidence
that question the statement was made or
published by ms heard
answer yes
question the statement was about mr depp
answer yes
question the statement was false answer
yes
question the statement has a defamatory
implication about mr depp
answer yes
question the defamatory implication was
designed and intended by ms heard
answer yes
question due to circumstances
surrounding the publication of the
statement
it conveyed a defamatory implication to
someone who saw it other than mr depp
answer yes
do you find that mr depp has proven by
clear and convincing evidence that ms
heard acted with actual malice
answer yes
three
as to the statement appearing in the
op-ed entitled a transformative moment
for women in the washington post print
edition
and the online op-ed
amber heard i spoke up against sexual
violence and faced our culture's wrath
that has to change
in the washington post online edition
quote i had the rare vantage point of
seeing in real time
how institutions protect men accused of
abuse
end quote
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes
has mr deb proven by a greater weight of
the evidence
that question the statement was made or
published by ms hurd
answer yes
question the statement was about mr deb
answer yes
question
the statement was false
answer yes
question the statement has a defamatory
implication about mr depp
answer yes
question the defamatory implication was
designed and intended by ms heard
answer yes
question due to circumstances
surrounding the publication of this
statement it conveyed a defamatory
implication
to someone who saw it other than mr
death
answer yes
do you find that mr depp has proven by
clear and convincing evidence that ms
heard acted with actual malice answer
yes
as against amber heard we the jury award
compensatory damages in the amount of 10
million dollars as against amber heard
we the jury award punitive damages in
the amount of 5 million dollars
in civil case number cl 2019-2911
ms heard's claim against mr depp
one
as to this statement appearing in the
april 8 2020
online edition of the daily mail
quote
amber heard and her friends in the media
use fake sexual violence allegations as
both a sword and shield depending on
their needs
they have selected some of her sexual
violence hoax facts as the sword
and flick inflicting them on the public
and mr depp
do you find that ms heard has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer no
two
as to this statement appearing in the
april 27
2020 online edition of the daily mail
quote
quite simply this was an ambush a hoax
they set mr depp up by calling the cops
but the first attempt did not do the
trick
the officers came to the penthouses
thoroughly searched and interviewed and
left after seeing no damage to face or
property
so amber and her friends spilled a
little wine and roughed the place up
got their story straight under the
direction of a lawyer and publicist and
then placed a second call to 9-1-1
end quote do you find that ms heard has
proven all the elements of defamation
answer yes
has ms heard proven by a greater weight
of the evidence
that question mr waldman
while acting as an agent for mr death
made or publish the statement answer yes
question the statement was about ms
heard answer yes
question the statement was seen by
someone other than misheard answer yes
question the statement was false
answer yes
do you find that ms heard has proven by
clear and convincing evidence that the
statement by mr waldman was made with
actual malice
answer yes
three
as to this statement appearing in the
april 27
2020 online edition of the daily mail
quote we've reached the beginning of the
end of miss heard's abuse hoax against
johnny depp end quote
do you find that ms heard has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer no
as against john c depp ii we the jury
award compensatory damages in the amount
of two million dollars
as against john c depp ii
we the jury award punitive damages in
the amount of zero dollars
does either side wish to have the jury
pulled yes your honor all right jamie
members of the jury if this is your
verdict please answer yes
if this is not your verdict please
answer no
juror number six
juror number 10
juror number 15
juror number 16.
your juror number 22
juror number 27
juror number 29
yes
i do find that the jury's verdict is
unanimous ladies and gentlemen this
concludes your service in this case i
want to thank you again for your
dedication and your hard work during
this trial and i know i speak for
everybody here
when i appreciate tell you that we
appreciate your sacrifices and your time
and your public service in this matter
okay so i'm going to have you go back to
the jury deliberation room for one more
uh time and then we'll release you from
there okay all right thank you
all right
okay in accordance with law i will amend
the punitive damages
award to the statutory cap of 350 000 on
mr depp's award okay
i will set this down for entry of an
order and can we do it on june 24th at
10 am if that's available
all right mr two if you could prepare
that order and then circulate it to miss
frederhof and we can have all the
objections noted on it all right
thank you very much all right and if i
get it before that date i'll take it off
the docket okay all right again thank
you to all the attorneys uh for your
professionalism and uh you're welcome to
come to my courtroom anytime well give
me a few weeks but then you can come any
time okay all right report is adjourned
thank you
you